hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to oxygen not included
now I am NOT going to let my people die
I'm going to grow very attached to them
and I'm going to be very attentive to
their needs now in the last one I did
not realize that oxygen did not spread
completely through the open area that
you were so that was my problem I didn't
think that would happen they all
suffocated to death and that's very bad
so I've got Gus mystique and Sybil here
through supposedly but this Gus just
wants everyone to be happy
Mystique's defy all labels Sybil's
always get what they want even when they
shouldn't so this like some weird
dynamic here where these are
quote-unquote duplicates so I think what
these are these are copies of people
like the portal thing that they came
through they have a template person so
when it says this Gus just wants
everyone to be happy
Gus is a type of duplicate that they
have and you can always expect them to
be similar because when you shuffle
through them you've add Sadie Sadie and
then they each have different attributes
but it's really interesting
whoa level 9 run or holy [ __ ] level 8
minor
I'll take this this looks good Gus Josie
Lenny you guys are going to be my
bamboos and I want to get with the
incredible fortress but not so cute
cantaloupe but not so duplicate beyond
the uh the uncomfortable space prison
yeah that seems about right
but at least in this prison you won't
die
oh good water is actually closer by okay
so it'd be best to start digging I know
I know I got it so what we're going to
do is we're going to do our best here
we're going to just dig this out we're
gonna whatever the hell these are we're
going to dig these we're just going to
keep digging I'm gonna dig a whole bunch
and everything's gonna be good so I'm
assuming that the glowy blueness in the
background there that is oxygen oh it is
oxygen you can just go over and that's
what it is so as they keep digging I'm
revealing more of the oxalate that's
going to be able to provide all the
oxygen that I need in the beginning so
in this one I'm going to try to
establish a better face because there's
one thing that I didn't do it to save us
a very good face so and also
intelligently dig towards the thing to
where oxygen is already provided like
over here there's already I oh my god
[ __ ] it back oh I did not know that
there were going to be other creatures
in this game that is news to me okay so
that's interesting
there are definitely new creatures to
explore that's fast so I'm gonna leave
this narrow because I just want to come
over here so I can have oxygen there and
there is oxygen down there too so that
water has been oxygenated in some way
I'm going to loop back around and
eventually come down to that one I'm
just going to try to do it in a way that
doesn't make everyone die okay I think
they can go down on one like one
platform they can walk through there at
least that'll be the test so if they can
try to dig out this piece of dirt there
dig that one no he cannot oh okay so
that's that is a limiting factor so they
cannot go down across single platform
things but the can cross here I think no
they cannot oh yeah they can a lazy sack
of crap are you doing over there you're
making me look bad
all right then so either way we need to
dig slow enough that oxygen can spread
everywhere that it needs to go and in
addition to that it can do everything
else to do I'm going to cancel that one
don't dig that one okay so we got to get
down to that water but we can't just
drop down that would be stupid
hey you got a mock root good job Josie
Josie you're doing it so proud I love
Josie Josie gosh Josie you're so good
it's so good what you do all right I'm
gonna build an outhouse because we
definitely do that
all right I'll help I hear about the
stinker room all right so we need to get
down to that water that is paramount
Josie's going over there oh so they each
pick there Oh each one is assigned to a
different person okay all right okay I
think there did that that's not bad
so by twos they can yeah they can climb
up and climb out of that there is oxygen
down there if they go down there then
suddenly they have access to water
correct yes do they need to actually
touch it to be accessible whoo well that
looks funky now water is behaving some
bizarre properties that I don't I don't
appreciate all right then it's very
sticky water gross all right then but
this is fine now we have at least some
oxygenated area and then we're doing
better on supply so we're going to keep
digging out here this is just dirt
that's good cultivatable soil I like the
sound of that
I like the side of our so we need to buy
old hmm so what should we do we need we
need a lot of more resources here so
this is where a lot of metal is so I'm
going to have them dig up to there
because I just want to get the right
places to dig to and then
that should do it
right that'll be it all right go for it
guys go for it run I said they're doing
this thing they're going to dig they're
going to dig they're going to tick
they're going to tick it dig dig dig dig
dig dig dig dig dig dig dig come on guys
hurry up you got a lot of work to do
don't be oh they don't have oxygen up
there okay so they're a little bit of
they're just a little bit of running out
of oxygen which is not good you don't
have to you don't have to kill yourself
guys you don't have to do that you can
go back down you can go back down at any
time now
I know go for it freeze right you're
fine you're fine hold your breath you're
good y'all good okay the oxygen will
eventually flow up there I think unless
it just won't flow that far so what they
could do is they could build oh man that
is just that is literally just ah there
goes there goes okay so if it's really
cool there's like a fluid dynamics to
the oxygen around here and a lot of
gases so they all they all want to
occupy the space with their in so all
right so now that we got that we got
some more there we can actually start
making some stuff we can make power
general well I guess I'm Jose you do not
die up there
Josey I swear to God Josey why did you
pass out right then and there
these duplicants do not behave correctly
he's okay I think Josie's gonna be okay
this is a little scare you know you
scare me not not accessible there's such
sweet little bodies oh I want you to not
die I just don't want you to die I think
you shouldn't die
is that noble of me to say is that
responsible and mature of me to say I
don't want you guys to die it's true I
don't I believe in all of these I'm just
gonna dig this out a little more so we
have access to go over here what is that
absolute no no that means obsidian cool
I guess good stuff maybe I don't know
I'm hoping that more oxygen is gonna be
able to go through this okay then you
guys do your thing suck your food out of
the jail the Box gone God suck that food
out you got it you're doing great guys
come on hurry up come oh we got stuff to
do we got stuff to do come on don't you
see our house now come on
get it get it get it get it go go go go
get get get get get you go go I didn't
plan that out very well but you guys
hurry up let's do your thing
more oxygen exposes that's good okay
good good good good good
okay Jimmy baby to be able to be able to
be able to be able to be able to be able
to boo good good good good good good
okay so they're gonna do their thing and
they're going to keep digging the only
problem is oxygen is just a little bit
spares over there that's fine because
what I can do is I can make an oxygen
generator over there because there's
oxygen right here so put that there put
it there but they're put there and then
oxygen production put that there right
there and then that should be good oh
wait let me wire that up okay put that
there put there right there good good
I'm good
oh it's running under oxygen come on
hurry up we got to get oxygen in here
please please hurry up there we go ha ha
look at that
oh gosh gosh you okay buddy all right
that battery's full and that's gonna
produce oxygen we're good we're doing a
lot better than we were I mean we're not
doing great but we're doing better than
we were okay so oxygen is filling up
that area then we're going to be able to
mine out all this stuff like I think we
can do a four-block so just get that
stuff Dig Dug and then I'm going to look
into more interesting things to do here
like the food processor electrical
wiring put the fare sweet it up go for
it big boys go for it guys guys guys
woo Thank You Josie and I would have one
of those in my house I always wanted
renewable energy just through a bike
like if I had to power my computer with
a bike I would be in such good shape
because I never be on the computer now
what I don't know is if they're going to
be able to fill if they're gonna be able
to go get water from the water place cuz
I might need to dig that out a bit
better I don't know though make maybe oh
wait yeah you're beautiful you're
beautiful it's true oh you're not
beautiful off to consuming contaminated
oxygen oh is that what the slime
produces slime produces contaminated
oxygen oh is that good though is that a
good thing should I trust you I don't
know if I should trust you but I'm gonna
come talk to you in a bit after I build
my [ __ ] I'm doing feel good okay so it
doesn't have I don't have meal lice
which is the problem I don't know where
the hell to get that wrong
that's something you grow there's
something that I could grow to a
tasteful memorial oh that's that okay
all right then let's see I should feel
bad I should build bad for my bleep oh
look at that
I am bad and then an eventual bed for
someone else whoever wants to join go
for it looky those time for the cycle
anyway you're gonna need beds don't just
pass out in the middle of nowhere go to
a goddamn bad yeah there you go good job
Lenny you're doing great Lenny Gus
you're doing great too always hopeful
that someone's gonna be there so now the
question is are they gonna go
they actually I'm just gonna pass out
where they saying I felt those bad steps
of time I'll look at them we're so cute
I love you guys I love you guys okay so
it looks like we're going to need
eventually to build a research station
so that's what I'm going to do next do
this
to wiring up to this one I connect those
dots here there we go and then in the
next morning they'll build those things
we'll be able to research new
technologies we've got a new duplicate
on the way very soon looking up for us
things are going better than I thought
they were now the Dodge everyone's dead
I didn't know about the oxygen thing
okay I didn't know about that and
hopefully everything will be okay that's
weird because what that means is that's
nonstops always going to bring new
people in no matter what there's always
going to be new people coming through
that printing pod I can't exactly stop
that and maybe even it's going to
accelerate which is going to be really
stressful because you always have to
make sure that you have more and more
people like at the ready oh cool
research hell yeah
percolation sanitation pressure
management ok farming tech seems like
the most logical to do so we're going to
have that this uncomfortable space
prison it's going to be the top of
research no fabrication cute what does
that mean I don't know what that
fabricate I don't
ok novice research fabricate that do
that up fabricate it away why do you
need dirt for that god
got a mind real hard for that one yeah
all right then
Oh Gus is doing it go Gus go okay so you
need 20 research points to be able to
research that in the whole research tree
so farming tech is getting it first so
if you had multiple ones of those you
could do a lot of [ __ ] but it takes a
lot of power apparently so I just need
to constantly make sure that that has
all the fabrication it needs to be able
to conduct enough research and then
we'll be able to make food which is
going to be very important because we
don't have all the food in the world but
we got enough food to last us a while
the next duplicate the next babies gonna
be ready in no time
just Josie Josie Josie
oh she's a narcoleptic oh that's gonna
be bad if you fall asleep in a place
where you don't have old you're not
going there
chlorine will kill you in an instant
whoo boy oh boy
okay don't do that well that's a lot of
chlorine well that is a lot okay so we
got a lot of really interesting
materials over here but I don't know if
they're gonna be what we need also I
don't know how to build properly to go
up to where we need to go hello hi hello
who we got hello you didn't do duplicate
Oh oh look at you guys hello
Max's are painfully gullible and other
duplicates like to take advantage of it
every chance they get huh can't dig it
this duplicate just can't operate a dig
tool for the life of them bottomless
tough stomach oh man
oh no one ever asked for Pam's bad
opinions but she's always happy to offer
them anyway well I don't want people
that just can't dig that kind of sucks I
guess he's got good construction so he's
specialized as a builder and not as a
digger which I suppose is okay
I like max that's is cool print them
print them up whoa hi max welcome max
are you so cute max what are you gonna
do with your life what are you gonna do
insufficient oxygen generation Oh
okay so we need more oxygen generation
that's understood so we just need to
make another makes another oxygen
generator then all we need to do I hope
that's what we need to do pay attention
to that okay so hopefully max the
Builder oh no Lenny all right then max
you know you just you just play around
oh yes camp
yeah dorable scamp you just do what you
guys do max you do what you gotta do
okay so hopefully that's going to be
enough to be able to offset the oxygen
generation crucial hey I need the
microbe
we gotta have more research come on
research Go Go Go Go come on
Oh continuously fabricate that's what I
need to do okay there we go continuously
fabricate that until if resource is
available okay so that's this going to
be constantly going max you're genius
you oh you smart guy are you so smart I
like that good job max okay so things
are looking in pretty good shape like
oddly enough things are surviving well
here so I think this is a good stopping
point for this episode and then in the
next one we're going to carry on and
make sure that they advance their life
just a little bit fun so thank you
everybody so much for watching hope you
enjoy the adventures of Gus Max Lenny
and Josie will be surprised and they're
probably not but with me in charging in
the uncomfortable space prism probably
not so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I'll see you in
the next video bye-bye
[Music]